you fool [ __ ] someone said it would
be funny if I just had one black and
white and I'm just showing old Joe Lewis
fights on it like really small actually
cool yeah
Joe Lewis verse who was the guy that he
he had these great fights with was it
Max Schmeling yeah yeah max Melling was
unfairly thought of as a Nazi who's
really just a German he's just a German
guy who's a boxer who really didn't want
to represent Hitler apparently from what
I've read yeah it was he the big rival
of Lois Whitney had these incredible he
stopped Lewis in the first fight and
then Louis destroyed him in the second
fight yeah and the big thing about him
beating Louis was that he beat Louis and
Louis was did he stop Louis hmm did you
think he did and Louis hardly ever law I
mean did he lose won two fights was that
he loses lost quite a few when he got
older in his career house to Rocky
Marciano by brutal knockout whoo
but that was he was quite a bit older I
think he was in his 40s at the time but
I think when he had the rematch I think
I think max Melling might have ko to him
and then when he had the rematch he
destroyed Max Schmeling here it is lost
by KO yeah yeah mmm does it say what
round 12 1912 36 yeah and then he came
back spare was another guy yeah he came
back and he was a giant hero when he
knocked out Schmeling in the first round
scroll up all the way how many years
later was that 38 yes you remembered
first round yeah all he smashed him yeah
I mean that was when Joe Lewis was Joe
Lewis I mean that was when he had really
come into his own and then he went on
this incredible tear they used to call
it the bum of the month club because he
was just locked knocking out anybody
who's willing to get in there with him
yeah he bought some legit guys and Billy
Conn fought him a couple of times who
was actually a line yeah yeah buddy bear
was that max bears
it says disqualified do you see that 49
and one I don't know what happened there
I wonder if that's a relation to max
bear probably the 1930s must have been
he imagined going back to the 30s the 40
so look at this he was the champ
all the way up to Ezzard Charles in 1950
think of that and he started in 36 yeah
so the fight with the first fight with
Max Baer was 36 with Max Schmeling
rather was 30 all right there yeah so
here e matched him in 38 the first fight
was in 36 took to you and he was all the
way the [ __ ] scroll all the way up to
the top by the time he lost he lost to
Jersey Joe Walcott a unanimous decision
in 1950 that's incredible that's 14
years later Wow [ __ ] crane Oh his
first loss was Charles sorry
yeah he KO Jersey Joe Walcott by the way
look at that you know Yankee Stadium was
the venue for Les Chicago Stadium and
these were huge events yeah you know
when a bunch of fights after that he
lost the unanimous decision scroll all
the way up and then lost again to Rocky
Marciano so you really only lost three
times it looks like three buddy
believable three big ones in the later
stages of his career unless he lost
earlier what's his overall record
it was 66 and three according to that
yeah so three losses so one max Mayer
the brutal one to Rocky Marciano which
ended his career did you see that where
else the brutal one yeah you wanna watch
it I I love I love I grew up watching
boxing did yeah yep and it wasn't
pay-per-view it was ABC 59 yeah it was
like it was like Network yeah back then
and I there was something it wasn't
pay-per-view and they were free TV and I
really got into the sport like I was
like I would be like so psyched to see
this [ __ ] yeah I'd be like I would watch
you you remember a guy named Oscar Bona
Bona Bona via yeah he was like a broad
he was just like this kind of wild
brawler but it was a big guy and he'd
fight guys like I don't know if he
changed his name you Cassius Clay oh
what's this
this is Jersey this is a as a Charles
right is that a zit Charles oh yeah
that's the loss but that's not the one
we want to see we want to see the Rocky
Marciano one this is the one where
Ezzard Charles the first guy to beat him
and he beat him by unanimous decision
but look first
look how much smaller people were back
then like Rocky Marciano when he won the
heavyweight I died was 15 pounds lighter
than me is that right yeah think of that
and I think he was only 510 and that
might have been [ __ ] you know like
people are a little sketchy about how
tall they were like that you know yeah
they would try to find that Rocky
Marciano won this um yeah I mean I
believe at the time I think when he was
the champion 85 pounds maybe one night
and the Marciano was known like like
Marciano was known for like just having
unbelievable strength and his punches
like just [ __ ] is this yeah that's
that's what he was he was like is this
is this in yeah this wood ink of an
immigrant Brock town brawl like he was
from Massachusetts yeah Brockton is that
him mask he looks small yeah yeah he's
15 pounds lighter than me man
Lewis is alive Lewis isn't even that big
Lewis is probably 200 pounds back then
that was a heavy weight back then it's
just a different world people didn't
have that kind of food they didn't have
enough to eat they didn't have the
nutrition knowledge they didn't have
steroids they didn't have weightlifting
I mean they had weightlifting but boxers
really didn't engage in that it's very
rare they thought it stiffened you up
they didn't understand that the
stiffening you up is just as you're you
know getting sore and that you have to
recover from that and that's how you get
bigger and stronger like boxers today if
you look at like Anthony Joshua who's
the heavyweight champion the world now
is look at him yeah he's a English
fellow he's a tank I mean he's a man you
look at Anthony Joshua he looks like
like a superhero do they do those guys
have as much stamina as these guys do
without yeah they do yeah because
there's conditioning methods that they
have today are just so superior they
understand rest and recovery and they
monitor your heart rate and you know
they're they're monitoring lactic acid
buildup and creatine in your blood and
so the science is really it's it's such
a scientific if they engage in that at
you know some some people still take it
old-school but I just think they know
more about what gets you in condition
and high intensity you know conditioning
drills
hi Reza rocky marciano had something
that you can't teach people which is
just brutal route strength
brutal power he just had the ability to
land these bone crushing shots and he
also was insanely tough you're dealing
with a just a different time like a
conversation with my wife this morning
we were talking about old-school keep
that going keep that going to see the
end is brutal
oh he just knocked down hit a little up
took drop them and this is you know an
older Joe Lewis how old was Joe Lewis at
the time of this young Jamie did say and
rock and Marciano how old was Marciano
he was as prime I think Marciano was 30
or something it's a lot smaller than him
to say no he was older yeah 1951 he got
knocked out by Marciano that's crazy
god I love Braddock I love that
Cinderella story you see them vessel
Crowe is like [ __ ] good great yeah